this is a desperate hunt to evacuate
people from frontline villages that look
destined to fall to russian forces in
the coming days they're just a few miles
away
[Music]
emergency services have had calls
pleading for help from people in the
town of solidar
[Music]
they're risking their lives looking for
the people who want to leave but they
can't find them
italian
is the only person left in her apartment
block but she won't go
i'll tell you why don't you want to
leave
[Music]
these towns and villages appear deserted
but there are plenty of people still
here the fighting is intense nearby
people call for help and they just
simply don't turn up to be evacuated
it seems counter-intuitive but
the more danger the more the bombing the
less people actually want to leave their
homes they prefer to actually stay where
they feel at least safe rather than get
in this truck and go to another city
it means that they just sort of stay
here
[Applause]
he's the
uh emergency services uh guy who's
showing us around us has said basically
from that position if they're firing
he'll be in coming here
the crews gather to discuss the next
destination
truck it's a form of armored personnel
carrier they call it the capsule it can
seat 17 in the back
we've had to
change direction because the road that
we were traveling down is now seeing
direct fire between the ukrainian
and russian forces this truck is so big
it is armored but it's so big it'll take
direct hits potentially from missiles
which would still
destroy it
we weave our way towards that next
destination
along the ukrainian lines
we reach another group cooking outside
there's no water or power anymore
[Music]
they start arguing if one of them should
go before agreeing they won't
they're choosing to stay here
underground in the darkness as 23 people
including children
they collect water in buckets
their radio is their only contact with
the outside world
it's miserable but it is home
european
she gets more and more upset
it's very sad
they're very very upset most sad
[Music]
the crews are already in the midst of
the fighting
but they insist that they'll continue to
go out day after day until they can't go
anymore
and nobody knows when that will be
mr ramsey sky news in the donbass